GOOD MORNING ONE WELCOME
EVERYONE TO THE WEDNESDAY MARKS
THE TWENTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MEETING OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
LIKE TO ASK MA'AM SECRETARY IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE.
I NORTH.
DALY.
YOUR FAILED HERE TROLLING.
SHOWING HERE GLORIA GIPSON
GLORIA. MOM.
WHAT?
WE HAVE A QUORUM TO BEGIN AND I
KNOW OTHER MEMBERS WILL BE
JOINING US SHORTLY.
SINCE I WILL BE PRESENTING BOTH
OF THE BILL'S TODAY I AM GOING
TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER. TO
MISTER GLORIA
.
I TRY TO DO YOUR JOB.
YOU COULD.
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR. OF
WELCOME FORTY AYE PISA.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
AB TWENTY ONE C.
HE WON.
BOTH OF THE BILLS THAT WILL BE
CONSIDERING TODAY ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WHICH WE HAVE IN ADDITION. TO
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE'RE LIVING AT A TIME
OPTICALLY THIS PAST YEAR WHEN
WE'RE READING ABOUT IN THE
NEWSPAPERS TENT ENCAMPMENTS IN
EVERY CITY AND. REGION OF OUR
STATE.
HOMELESSNESS CAUSED BY FIRE AND
MUDSLIDES HEPATITIS A AND E.
COLI OUTBREAKS.
OUR AT THIS TIME CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST HOMELESSNESS RATES
IN THE COUNTRY. TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF AMERICA'S HOMELESS
ARE IN CALIFORNIA FORTY TWO
PERCENT OF AMERICA'S CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN RECENT YEARS WE HAVE ALSO
SEEN THE HIGHEST INCREASE IN
THESE NUMBERS AND BY HIDES
FEDERAL.
NUMBERS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
THEY ESTIMATE THAT WE HAVE
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS
ARE ON OUR STREETS WHICH OF MANY
OF US BELIEVE IS LIKELY AN
UNDERCOUNT.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS LEADS TO ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR GOVERNMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
ARE CORRECTION SYSTEM A MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM OR SOCIAL SERVICE
SYSTEM.
AND I THINK EVERYONE WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND IT TO UNDERSTAND
IT WE NEED TO MEASURE AND
ANALYZE DATA IF YOU CAN'T
MEASURE WHAT'S GOING ON. YOU
CAN'T SOLVE IT SO AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE IS A BILL FOCUSED ON
HOMELESS DATA COLLECTION. IT
WOULD ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
DATABASE TO COMPILE AND
CENTRALIZED HOMELESSNESS DATA WE
ASK EACH CD TO WORK WITH THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCE COUNCIL TO DO THAT. THIS
WOULD BE DATA RECEIVED FROM A
VARIETY OF STATE AGENCIES AS
WELL AS LOCAL AGENCIES ON WHO IS
HOMELESS WHY. WHAT SERVICES ARE
WE PROVIDING TO THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING WHAT GAPS AND PROGRAMS
WE HAVE? THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND THE
IMPACT ON PUBLIC PROGRAMS.
WE ALSO.
INCLUDE PROVISIONS TO ADDRESS
PRIVACY ISSUES AND I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THERE ARE OTHER STATES
IN FRONT OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS. MICHIGAN
CONNECTICUT OHIO AND NOW NEW
YORK IS STARTING TO PROCESSES
DATA. OUR THANK OUR SPONSORS
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS.
SOME.
HI I AM I AM A VERY WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AND.
.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE SOULS TO
ESSENTIAL PROBLEMS ONE WITHIN
THE HOMELESS DATA ITSELF AND ONE
ACROSS SYSTEMS.
SO. EACH
CONTINUE OF CARE HAS ITS OWN
DATABASE OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THOSE DATABASES STONE PARK
WHICH OTHERS SO IF SOMEONE IS
RECEIVING SERVICES
AND HOMELESS WHEN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS WE
ARE TRANSIENT POPULATION OF
SEVEN TH RECEIVE SERVICES IN.
MORE THAN ONE COUNTY THE BE
PRESENT IN MORE THAN ONE
DATABASE.
AND THEY'LL BE COUNTED MORE
THAN ONCE IF YOU TRY TO COMPILE
STATEWIDE NUMBERS.
AND ALSO PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS
AS THE ASSEMBLYMANTHIRD ARE
LIKELY TO BE RECEIVING CRISIS
SERVICES TO YOU GO TO THE ER.
THEIR JUSTICE INVOLVED.
BUT IF THERE ISN'T A GOOD WAY
TO.
ANALYZE
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS AND THOSE SERVICE
SINCE.
IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T ONE DATABASE THAT
TELLS YOU WHO WHO'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAS ALSO BEEN IN
THE ARMY IS ALSO. JUST AS
INVOLVED.
SO BY BRINGING ALL THIS DATA
SETS TOGETHER IT'S POSSIBLE TO
CONDUCT THESE LONGITUDINAL
STUDIES THAT WOULD TELL YOU.
BOTH WHAT SERVICES ARE BEING
USED.
AND WHAT SERVICES ARE NEEDED.
OF THE CURRENT COST OF THE
SYSTEM AND TO THE TRUE COST OF
DOING NOTHING.
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU COULD SEE THE
COSTS THAT ARE BEING GENERATED
BY PEOPLE NOT GETTING THE
HOUSING THAT THEY NEED NOT BEING
STABLE HOUSE TO NOT BEING ABLE
TO AVOID CRISIS CARE AND TO GET
PREVENTIVE SERVICES OR DIVERSION
SERVICES FROM.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
.
AND.
I I WOULD ALSO JUST SAY ONE MORE
THING WHICH IS THAT IN
IMPLEMENTING. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE IT'S GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO BRING AND THE
VARIOUS CONTINUANCE OF CARE
TOGETHER TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
ABOUT HOW THE DATA WILL BE
SHARED AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY A PLATFORM THAT
WOULD CONVERSATION ABOUT A
SHARED VISION FOR THE STATE OF
HOW WE GET TO A PATH TO AND
HOMELESSNESS.
SO CONVERSATIONS ABOUT DATA
SOUND
BORING IN THE ABSTRACT BUT THEY
CAN VERY OFTEN ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY
CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN THE
DATA. BE THE BASIS FOR SHARED.
WORK FAR OUT EXCEEDING JUST THE
COMPOSITION OF THE DIVISION
ITSELF.
BIGGEST PERRY I THINK YOU
SHOULD A WILL OF GOD IT NOW AS A
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MEANWHILE MUST COME FORWARD AND.
.
SHARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
GOOD MORNING.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASED THE CO SPONSORS BILL
AND HAPPIEST WHERE THINKING
BECAUSE THERE.
GOOD MORNING HER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
PARTICULARLY.
THE NEED FOR DATA I THINK HIS
EX
STREAMLINED IMPORTANT THESE DAYS
AS WERE FACING A NUMBER OF
DECISIONS AND PARTICULARLY THAT
ARE IMPACTING PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS WE START LOOKING TO
EXPANDING CONSERVATORSHIP CENTER
NIMBY ISSUES THAT.
REALLY SEEM TO BE OUT THERE AND
I THINK THE MORE INFORMATION THE
DAY THAT WE CAN PUT TOGETHER AND
USE I THINK WILL BE HELPFUL TO
YOU ALL AND I SAW IN LOOKING AT
THAT THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
I INITIAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE RACING UP TO SPEAK
ANY ILLNESS OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE YOU HAD YOUR
OPPORTUNITY ARE IT WILL. TURN TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER CHAIR.
THE MOTION FOR APPROVAL BY CITY
NEVER DALY. SUCH A CHOICE YOU
HAVE SOME COMMENTS.
YEAH I WANNA MAKE A CALM THAT.
O. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHOOSE I FO
DOT TO.
SOLVE.
.
TO ISSUES OF HOMELESSNESS.
WHICH IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT THOUGHT I'M WONDERING.
THIS A CREATION OF OUR NEW DATA
WAREHOUSE.
WHICH I READ IN THE FISCAL NOTE.
EFFECT IS SO UNKNOWN.
DO YOU HAVE.
.
ESTIMATED.
COSTA HOW MUCH IT'LL COST.
BUT I WOULD IMAGINE. IT WOULD BE
IS. SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS IF
NOT THE IN EVEN TWO DIGITS.
.
TO ME.
IT IS A LIE CHO WENT THE DESCENT
LACK OF.
DATA.
I HAS BEEN THE PROBLEM IS
SOLVING THIS SO HOMELESSNESS.
AND THAT THIS HAS SOUGHT TO ME.
DIVERTING THAT.
THE MONEY THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
USED TO.
EVEN HELPING.
A FEW MORE.
NOT THE US AND IF NOT THE
HUNDREDS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE.
AND OTHER BUREAUCRACY. TO SPEND.
YOU NO CREATING OF ARE NOT DATA
WAREHOUSE ARE IS A NOT JUST A
FACT OF LIFE. A DATABASE.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A FACILITY
WOULD HAVE. PUSHED NOW TO
SUPPORT. AND I I THINK I DO SO
FISCAL IMPACT AROUND ANALYSIS OF
WHETHER THIS IS SO REALLY GREAT
THE WAY OUR FOR SPENDING THAT
KIND OF THE MONEY. TOSS MY
QUESTION.
ARE. YOU KNOW EFFORT IS SO
NOBLE.
BUT IT IS SO.
.
A QUESTIONABLE WHETHER.
THE SUB BETTER WAY OF EXPANDING
ON WHAT RESOURCES.
WHETHER THIS A LACK OF.
A DATA.
I EVEN CROSSED THE STREET.
WE WAY WE WE FISCALLY SEE THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
BUT THE AVE THERE BECAUSE HAVE
WELL. THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE.
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
AND.
IS A QUITE INTERESTING TO READ.
DE OPPOSITION OUR ARGUMENT.
BUT IDEA.
.
ANALYSIS SO HERE.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A. S.
B. AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO CREATE THE.
COORDINATING COUNCIL THE
WHOLENESS OF ADVOCATES
HEY IN.
HATED IT. AS HIS SOLUTION.
TO INDIA.
MANAGING THE DIVERSE A PROGRAM
SO TO SOFT IS SO ELUSIVE UP
PROBLEM.
OR THOUGHT HE COUNTS ON.
HAS ONLY BEEN NOT IN EFFECT. A
SCANT THE FIFTEEN MONTHS.
THE SAME ADVOCATES ARE EVER
RETURNED. INSISTING THAT. A WHAT
THE STATE THE REALLY NEEDS IS
SOME MORE DATA.
AT THE MINIMUM
THE DATABASE. OF CAN BE
ESTABLISHED.
BUT MR DE REALLY.
AND THE.
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
WORSE THOSE STATE THAT CREATES A
THESE
A ANOTHER REQUIREMENT.
Y. EL.
D. PROBLEM GOALS.
BESIDES THE. LEGISLATURE ALREADY
PASSED SO NO PLACE LIKE HOME IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CREATING.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS. IN NEW
FUNDING.
FOR CONSTRUCTION OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING UNITS.
OR SO ON NOVEMBER THIS YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BALLOT. VOTERS
TO OR CONSIDER APPROVING.
AND OTHER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
BOND TO FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THAT INCLUDE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS SO FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
WITH THE NEW MONEY.
THAT IS SO.
.
LIKELY TO BE GENERATED WHEN THIS
PASSES. I THINK JUST SHOULD BE
OUT OF THIS MONEY CAN BE. USED
LET MR DUTIFULLY BUY THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS RATHER THAN
CREATING AND OTHER. OF
BUREAUCRATIC. LAW AGENCY OUGHT
TO CREATE A SUCH A DATA
WAREHOUSE IN THE MANAGE THEM
SO ARE ARTICULATE WOULD IT BE
BETTER. I USE ALFA SUCH
RESOURCES SO.
OUT FOR ADMISSION BUREAUCRACY
PURPOSES RATHER THAN HELPING TO
HOMELESS PEOPLE DIRECTLY THAT'S
MY QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR FOR THAT QUESTION
AND AS YOU SAID A LOT IN YOUR
STATEMENT SO LET ME TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME ASPECTS OF IT.
YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL OF YOU
STATE AT THE OUTSET THIS MAY NOT
BE THE BEST USE OF MONEY AND
THERE MAY BE OTHERS AND IF YOU
HAVE SOLUTIONS AND WHAT YOU
THINK WE OUGHT TO DO TO ADDRESS.
THE MOST INTENSE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS I THINK MANY OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED I'D BE HAPPY TO TO
MEET WITH YOU TO UNDERSTAND YOUR
IDEAS. ON THIS IS ONE OF OUR MY
IDEAS AND AND AND HOW WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS.
I THINK YOU ALSO SAID THAT WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHOSE
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SOLUTIONS
ARE AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE WHAT
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING IS THAT.
WE COLLECT THIS DATA SO WE
UNDERSTAND WHO'S HOMELESS ON THE
STREETS
WHY THEY HOMELESS WHAT SERVICES
THEY RECEIVE AND WHAT ARE THEY
NOT RECEIVING. AND WHAT'S
EFFECTIVE AND WHAT'S COST
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE WE KNOW.
THAT WE ARE SPENDING.
I. PROBABLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
HOMELESSNESS IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT WE'RE NOT.
BRINGING DOWN THOSE NUMBERS IN
FACT THEY CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET
AND WE NEED TO BE SMART AND. AND
HOW WE DO THAT. NOW WITH REGARDS
EXPENDITURE UP WE ARE AT THIS
MOMENT ARE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
AGENCIES TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THIS AND COST EFFECTIVE WAY I DO
NOT THINK IT'S GONNA BE IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND I THINK IT'LL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN THAT BUT
I'D SUGGEST.
THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE A
PENNY WISE POUND FOOLISH
DECISION TO NOT SPEND A LITTLE
BIT OF MONEY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE PROBLEM LOOKS LIKE SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CITIES THAT
HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO BUILD SUPPORT
OF HOUSING. EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
THAT IF YOU'RE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS A TYPICAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES SPEND ANYWHERE FROM
FORTY TO SIXTY TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR A
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS PERSON WHO
IS NOT HOUSED IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING RATHER THAN SAY FIFTEEN
OR TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
HOUSE AND HOW DO WE KNOW THIS WE
KNOW THIS BECAUSE A COUPLE OF
JURISDICTIONS. HAVE HAD THAT
DATA. AND IF WE CAN COLLECT THAT
DATA STATEWIDE AND REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. WE JUST HEARD FROM OUR
WITNESS.
THAT THERE ARE LIKELY QUITE A
FEW HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS THAT
TRAVEL FROM CITY TO CITY OR
COUNTY TO COUNTY TO USE
REDUNDANT SERVICES. WE KNOW THAT
ANECDOTALLY BUT WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH THAT'S COSTING
US IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
THE CORRECTION SYSTEM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM OR OTHERWISE AND
SO. PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS.
TO INVEST A FEW DOLLARS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS DATA LOOKS
LIKE SO WE CAN USE OUR MONEY
MORE SMARTLY KNOWS FIRST WHERE
THE MONIES COME FROM YES IT'S
ABSOLUTE TRUE THAT.
WE WILL HOPEFULLY BE INVESTING
MORE MONEY IN HOMELESS SERVICES
IN THE COMING YEARS AND I WOULD
BE FINE IF OF A DECISION WAS
MADE TO TO PULL SOME OF THAT
MONEY TO TO ACHIEVE THIS BUT. MY
BROADER POINT IS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THIS DATA WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
SPEND THOSE MONIES AND SO THAT'S
REALLY THE POINT OF THE BILL.
AND I THOUGHT THAT WOULD JUST
END BY SAYING I KNOW YOU'RE A
PHD AND I THINK YOU APPRECIATE
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING DATA
AND EVIDENCE.
BEFORE YOU MOVE FORWARD ON
POLICIES AND HYPOTHESES AS TO
WHAT TO DO AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS IS A.
THANK YOU RICHARD.
MAY I JUST SO YOU KNOW FOLLOW
UP ARE AYE AYE AYE AYE NO DATA
ARE ARE ARE IMPORTANT UP BUT UP
WHAT DOT.
BASICALLY.
WHEN I HEAR FEWER DAUGHTERS SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S SO AND IF
YOU THE HARRIS ADDED BE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF THE
AUDITORS. YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
THAT MONEY CAN BE USED.
ACTUALLY HELPING BECAUSE WE WE
PHYSICALLY NORMAL.
LIKE.
IF YOU APPROACH.
THAT IT IS CITY OF A SACRAMENTO.
BUTTON THAT WOULD HAVE OUR
ESTIMATE NUMBER. AND THOUGH
WHERE CONCENTRATED POPULATION
ARE AND ACADEMICALLY ANALYZING
WHAT COST AT THE HOMELESSNESS
AND OF THEM MENTAL STATUS SO
WHAT ARE THEY REALLY ACTUALLY
HELPING THEM.
WE KNOW FISCALLY VIA PAYER HOW
WE CAN USE HAVE TO MONEY
ACTUALLY STATES HAVE BEEN.
THE HOMELESS PEOPLE RATHER THAN
THIS UP BUREAUCRATIC. YOU KNOW
STUDY RESEARCH ORIENTED THAT
DATA HAUSA W. TO REALLY SOLVE
THE PROBLEM LAST.
MAY I. FINISH UP BY MY QUESTION
YOU KNOW IF I I'M I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO EVERY WORD YOU SAY
IT'S FAIRLY REPETITIVE I THINK
YOU'VE MADE YOUR POINT MISTER
CHOI YEAH I'M I'M REALLY JUST
BEING DISTURBED THOUGH WHEN NOT
YEAR TRY TO CUT ME OFF OF WHEN
WE. DON'T KNOW WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS MEETING NOW IF
WE DON'T HAVE TASK TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
BUT YOU'RE NOT ASKING QUESTIONS
TO.
GO AHEAD PLEASE ASK TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION IF YOU HAVE ONE SIR.
BUT I'VE MADE I THINK WE
UNDERSTOOD THE POINT YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT IRAQ CHRISSY IN
THE MISUSE OF FUNDS I THINK WE
HAVE MADE THE POINT.
THANK YOU SIR.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO ASK.
CHIEF QUESTION.
NO I JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
POINT WHICH IS A IS DATA WITH
THE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING SPENT.
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
MONEY THAT'S ALREADY BEING SPENT
AS WELL AS MONIES THAT MAY BE
SPENT IN THE FUTURE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE GOOD SOLID
STATE WIDE DATA. IN MY OWN
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY WITH THIRTY
FOUR CITIES IT'S HARD TO GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER FROM ANY
PARTICULAR AUTHORITY ABOUT.
WHERE THE HOMELESS LIVE HOW MUCH
MONEY'S BEEN IS BEING SPENT TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM?
THE COUNTY.
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAVE THE ANSWERS
AS WE'VE SEEN JUST IN THE LAST
FEW DAYS WERE A FEDERAL JUDGE
HAD TO INTERVENE. AND MANAGE
BASICALLY MANAGE THE COUNTY'S
MONEY BECAUSE THE COUNTY. DID
NOT KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY IT HAD
THEY ALSO CAN'T REALLY CALCULATE
HOW MANY HOMELESS. PERSONS THERE
ARE SO YOU HAVE A A REAL
MISMATCH.
IN TERMS OF MANAGING THE
SITUATION SO WE MUST HAVE GOOD
DATA STATEWIDE AND COUNTY BY
COUNTY AND JURISDICTION BY
JURISDICTIONS SO I THINK THIS IS
A VERY. HELPFUL BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR UP MISSED LOOK
THIS MONTH MS LIMON BEFORE WE DO
CAN I STAB SHOW A QUORUM FOR
CREATES I THINK WE ARE TO
ESTABLISH THE COURT YOU ALREADY
OKAY I THINK EVERYONE'S HERE
NOW.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GET ALMOST
EVERYONE IS LIMON THANK YOU AND
AND. I JUST I I WANTED TO SHARE
AND.
DAD TO IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
AT DATA'S BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM
BUT ALSO TO HELP US. UNDERSTAND
THEAPPROPRIATE SOLUTIONS SO WE
DO A HOMELESS COUNT.
WITH LOCALS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT'S BEEN PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL SO I THINK FOR ME MY
REASONS FOR SUPPORTING THIS ALSO
INCLUDE THAT IT'S NOT JUST
UNDERSTANDING THE PROBLEM IT'S
UNDERSTANDING ALSO. THAT
INFORMATION THAT'S GOING TO LEAD
US TO THE MOST APPROPRIATE AND
BEST RESPONSE FOR THIS.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU IS
ADDED DO WE HAVE ANY IDEAS IN
TERMS OF I.
YOU KNOW WILL THIS BE ALIGNED
WITH WHAT I THAT WHAT SOME
COUNTIES MAYBE ALREADY DOING IS
ALIGNED WITH ANY OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS OR IS THIS REALLY
AN IDEA TO JUST HAVE A AND IT
WILL BE WORKED OUT THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO SHARE DATA WITH EACH
OTHER BUT IT'S BEEN HARD. AND
THIS IS NOT A TRIVIAL TASK AS WE
ALL KNOW DATA IS HARD TO COLLECT
AND FIGURE OUT A SHARED IN A WAY
PARTICULAR THAT PROTECTS
PRIVACY.
BUT I THINK EVERYONE FROM LOCAL
COORDINATING COUNCILS TO
COUNTIES TO THE STATE ALL WANT
THE STATE AND BE ABLE TO COMPARE
NOTES AND AND HOW IT IS THAT WE
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS GRAY AND
THEN I THINK IS A TRANSIENT
COMMUNITY TO THAT KNOWS THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS SOME FOLKS MOVE
FROM ONE COUNTY TO ANOTHER
THERE'S.
REALLY VALUE IN SEEING THIS SO
WITH THAT I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD
MOVE THE BILL SINCE WE DO HAVE
QUORUM.
PLACE THEM ON A MISTER DALY I
MOVE THE BILL BUT YOU WOULD HAVE
A SECOND IT NEVER GOT SO LITTLE
MOTION BY MISTER DALY SECOND BY
MS LIMON TUCKED AWAY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU OF MISTER
CHIEF RING THIS BEFORE WHEN I
FIRST READ THE BILL I THOUGHT
WOW WE DON'T DO THIS ALREADY.
THAT WAS MY RESPONSE WHEN IT WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THE DATA WILL BE
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE. AND.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT NOT JUST HOW
CITIES CLICK CLICK DATA BUT HOW
COUNTY TO COLLECT DATA. AND THE
MOVEMENT ARE JUST WITHIN
COUNTIES.
CAN BE CAN BE REALLY
CHALLENGING TO DO TO TO
UNDERSTAND BUT ALSO.
THAT KIND OF THE I THINK AS YOU
COLLECT THE DATA AS AS IT IS
COLLECTED WILL BUILD SEE WHAT OF
THE DISPARITIES IN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES VERSUS LARGE URBAN
AREAS AND. AND BECAUSE THEY WERE
THERE THERE ARE DISTINCTIVELY
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES THEIR SO.
AND EVERYBODY BELIEVES.
IN THEIR OWN CITIES THAT THAT IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS THAT
THEY FACE AND IDEAS.
A BUT THE SCALE IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY DIFFERENT BUT SO I I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BONE APPRECIATE
RECEIVING A FORD THINK IF.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD A JUST A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE.
.
MOTIVATION BEHIND THE BILL I
HAVE A SIMILAR EFFORT IN SAN
DIEGO WHERE ARE WE SHOOTING OF
CARE REALLY HAD NOT DONE MUCH ON
EACH IN MY S..
AND DOING IT. WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO SOME OF OUTCOMES
BASED THING NOW WE CLEARLY HAVE
CRISIS DOWN THERE SO. THIS IS
NOW WAY PANACEA BUT YOU CAN'T
SOLVE A PROBLEM WITHOUT DIDN'T
HELP YOU UNDERSTAND
SO I I GET THE TEMPLATE.
MY EXPERIENCE OF THAT LEAVES ME
A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BILL NOT THAT I WILL SUPPORT A
ONE VERY CLEAR I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS.
AT THE MENTION OF THE.
ABOUT THE PRIVACY ISSUES.
YOU KNOW HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO IDENTITY THEFT.
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SHARE
INFORMATION IS PRESENTED AND YOU
MADE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT PRIVACY
I SAW THEM NOTES IN THE REPORT
CAN YOU EXPAND UPON THAT HOW CAN
WE BE SURE.
AT THAT THE DATA FOR THAT
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS
THE DATA FOR THEIR HOME FOR THE
VIGIL CONTINUED TO CARE FOR
WHICH THEY THE CUSTODIANS OF
THIS INFORMATION. BUT IT'S
PROTECT IT WILL BE BREACHED
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL LIABILITY
THAT WE'RE CREATING FOR THEM BY
PASSING THIS BILL
SO FOR SMALL THAT IS ACTUALLY
OUR INTENT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT DATE IS NOT PREACHING WE
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST NOTE IN THE
BILL AYE IT SPECIFICALLY STATES
THAT THE DATA WAREHOUSE SHALL
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF HIDES.
A HMS STANDARDS AND PROTECTING
PRIVACY OUGHT TO THAT'S THE
STARTING POINT BUT THAT BEING
SAID WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS AS
WE SPEAK WITH ADVOCATES. AYE AND
DIFFERENT COORDINATING COUNCILS
AROUND THE STATE ON WHETHER
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL PRIVACY
LAYERS THAT WE SHOULD ADD TO
WHAT IS THE FEDERAL STANDARD. A
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
ARE FACING IS WE'RE GONNA BE
ASKING FOR DATA FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND TYPES OF
AGENCIES AND THEY EACH HAVE.
PRIVACY STANDARDS.
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO ABIDE
BY SO.
WE WILL LIKELY BE.
LAYERING ON DIFFERENT PRIVACY
STANDARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF THOSE LAWS ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH WHICH I ABSOLUTE SUPPORTED
THINK WE NEED.
AND YOU GOT THE NEXT CONCERN I
HAVE WHICH IS THE THE DIFFERENCE
IS THE DATA BETWEEN COUNTIES
IMAGINES ONE OF THE VALUES AND.
THE KEYS WERE TO THIS MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT.
ISN'T STANDARDIZING THIS DATA
ON BUT I I KNOW WHAT WE WERE
COLLECTING PREVIOUS TO FINISHED
IF I HADN'T SAN DIEGO WAS PRETTY
MINIMAL. ON THE BACK END OF THIS
IT'S EXTREMELY DETAILED I'M NOT
JUST PUTTING NOT TRUE COST ALL
THE COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA IS
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL THIS
WRIST ENTERPRISE INFORMATION OR
YOU CAN ACCEPT THE DATE IN
WHATEVER FORM IT COMES FROM.
TOWN THAT'S ALSO THIS IS PART OF
THE CHALLENGE AROUND DATA I
THINK PART OF IT IS TO HAVE A
STANDARD SET OF DATA THAT WE CAN
COMPARE AND COLLECT FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES AS WELL AS FROM STATE
AGENCIES BUT. DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS ARE COLLECTING
DIFFERENT DEPTHS OF INFORMATION
SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA DISCOVER
OVER TIME WILL START WITH
PROBABLY BASIC DATASET AND THEN
SEE OVER TIME WHO'S DOING THE
BEST JOB OF COLLECTING DATA
THAT'S HOPEFUL AND AND PROBABLY
ADD TO THE DATABASE.
WELL I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I AM
I BUT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE INTO IS
IS GOOD I TOTALLY TRUST YOU ON
THIS ISSUE.
SO I HOPE YOU CONTINUE WORK ON
THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY I'M ON
STANDARDIZATION OF DATA YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE COMPARING APPLES AND
ORANGES YOU CAN'T REALLY COME TO
RELIABLE CAN KEEP CONCLUSIONS.
THAT'S AS IT EASIER SAID THAN
DONE.
IT WAS NOT EASY GETTING ALL THE
SAN DIEGO'S ALMOST PROVIDERS TO
GET ON THE SAME PAGE FOR.
DATA COLLECTION TOOL I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT THIS TASK WILL BE
STATEWIDE BUT I DO THINK THERE'S
EXTREME VALUE IN IT.
PREPS THE THE.
LAST THING I WOULD MENTION IS
AYE.
DOCTOR CHOICE MAKING THE POINT
ABOUT THE COSTS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND I
ACTUALLY WOULD ALIGN MYSELF MORE
CLOSELY WITH HIM. WITH REGARD TO
HOW MUCH THIS MAY COST YOU HAVE
ANY SENSE OF WHAT THIS MAY CAUSE
I IT SAYS UNKNOWN IS A FISCAL
IMPACT IN THE REPORT YOU MENTION
THAT YOU SORT OF TRY NATURE ARMS
AROUND THAT IS OUR IMPLEMENT
EVERY SORT OF BALLPARK. FIGURES
THAT YOU'VE SEEN AND ASK BY
STAFF OF FOR. WHAT IS LATEST
CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAD ON
THIS?
WHAT WE'RE TALKING EIGHT SEE
ABOUT COSTS BUT?
FOR HUD PROVIDES UP FRONT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SET UP
A.
A WAREHOUSE AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NEXT
ALL HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON THE
COST ISSUES OUT OF ANTI HAS
ANYTHING DATA.
I'M SORRY I DID ASK A FEW
EXPERTS FOR ESTIMATES AND THEIR
ESTIMATES WERE I AM. THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO COMMIT TO ANYTHING
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
VARIABLES WITH THEIR ESTIMATES
WERE ON THE SINGLE THE ONLY
SINGLE DIGIT MILLIONS NOT IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS.
WELL GOING BACK TO THE POINT
THAT HE MADE EARLIER A YOU KNOW
I WILL CALL ELISE FOR SAN DIEGO
IT DID IT WAS A SIMILAR SIZED
FIGURE FROM ONE COUNTY AND SO I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT. WILL
ULTIMATELY BE STATEWIDE.
I DON'T NEXT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A REASON NOT TO DO IT
BECAUSE WE ARE AT SUCH CHOICE
POINT THAT'S BEEN BILLIONS ON
THIS MATTER. ON MY HOPE FOR
THESE KINDS OF EFFORTS IS THAT
YOU CAN REDUCE DUPLICATION
I'M OF SERVICES PROVIDED.
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY START
MEASURING OUTCOMES OF THESE
PROGRAMS IN ALL PROGRAMS ARE
MIDDLE LIKE ARE AND IT'S NOT ALL
OF THEM HAVE GREAT OUTCOMES THAT
THIS DATA COULD HELP US TO
FIGURE OUT WHO THE GOOD ACTORS
ARE. AND STEER MORE THESE
LIMITED FUNDS TOWARDS THEM AND
DE FUND THOSE WHO DID NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT OUTCOMES ARE NOT
ALIGNED THEIR PROGRAMMES AT THE
POWERS THE STATE. I THINK THAT
WOULD BE THE WHERE THE.
DELIVERABLE FROM THIS I WOULD
NO I THINK WHAT STAFFERS WERE
GETTING TOO I THINK THIS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN THESE KINDS OF
EFFORTS I HOPE THAT WE WOULD.
AYE MY CONCERN IS TO MAKE SURE
THESE COSTS ARE NOT BORN ON BY
THE VIGIL CONTINUES OF CARE. AND
NONE OF THEM ARE PRETTY GOOD
WELL FUNDED I SPENT A LOT OF
TIME FUND RAISING FOR OUR LOCAL
EFFORTS AND ANY EFFORT THAT
WOULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL BURDENS BOTH COST IN
TERMS OF THAT THE.
I TEAR WHAT NOT WE DON'T STAFF
TIME WOULD BE OF SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU
SAN DIEGO CA BARRETT I COULD
IMAGINE A SMALL COUNTY WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO SO. IF WE CAN KEEP AN
EYE ON THAT GOING FORWARD OFFICE
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS BUT HE'S NOT
INSIGNIFICANT THINGS.
BUT NOTHING WORTH DOING
APPARATUS RIGHT SO.
I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR FOR.
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
DOUBLES ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS
BUT THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT SIDE OF WASN'T
LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORTING THIS
BILL THIS MORNING.
OUR INITIAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE.
SEEN AND WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISTER DALY WAS STRUCK BY MS
LIMON COULD I JUST MAKE A CAR
THAT'S RIGHT I FINAL COMMENTS NO
IS SO APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION AND IN
ONE THING I'LL NOTICE I LOOK AT.
EACH OF YOU AND THE DISTRICTS
YOU REPRESENT.
THE CHAIR REPRESENTS THE
DISTRICT WHERE WE SAW HEPATITIS
A OUTBREAK WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE
SEEN TENT ENCAMPMENTS ALONG THE
SANTA ANA RIVER.
WE HAVE TO REPRESENTATIVES FROM
SANTA BARBARA AS WELL AS FROM.
OUR OUR OUR NORTHERN COUNTIES
WHICH HAVE SEEN UP FIRES AND MUD
SLIDES THAT HAVE CREATED
THOUSANDS OF NEW HOMELESS
RESIDENTS. THIS IS A CRISIS WE
ALL HAVE TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND
AND AND LET ME ALSO SAY.
WE DON'T HAVETHE DATA THAT I
BELIEVE IS A STATE WE SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
ON HOMELESSNESS I'LL JUST SAY
FOR SAN FRANCISCO. THE LATEST
COUNT WE SPEND CLOSE TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR MY CITY OF EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND SO IF YOU
EXTRAPOLATE.
IT'S LIKELY WE'RE SPENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR AND
OUR HOPE IS THAT IF ASSUMING THE
SYSTEM COSTS A FEW MILLION A
SMALL FRACTION OF THAT.
THE THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO SAVE
MONEY IN THE LONG RUN AND TO BE
MORE EFFICIENT AND HOW WE TARGET
OUR DOLLARS. ARE IN THE LESSON
YOU'LL SEE IS IF THERE ARE OTHER
IDEAS AND I WOULD SAY THE
SPECIFICALLY TO OUR OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE IF THERE
OTHER IDEAS THAT YOU HAVE AND
HOW TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS I AM
VERY OPEN. UP WITH A CRISIS
WE'VE GOT ACT NOW AND I THINK IT
HAS TO START WITH UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS SO WITH
THAT.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
IT IS VERY ASSERTIVE PLEASE
FOLLOW. THE MOTION TO PASSING
pAPPROPRIATIONS STEINORTH.
DAILY.
DALY AYE CHOI NO SHOWING NO
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE WE MONTH.
LIMON I WOULD. PUT AYE CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE.
THAT.
IT'S FIVE TO.
TWO ZERO.
PHIL IF I WANT TO.
FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE ONE AM SO
YEAH YES FIVE ONE. A THAT THAT
MOTION PASSES
I.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
YOUR NEXT BOOK SURE LIKE TO ASK
MISTER BAILEY IF YOU LIKE TO
JOIN ME
.
SO MANY WOULD MAKE PROCEED
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
CONSIDERING.
A SECOND BILL TODAY ON THE
TOPIC OF HOW WE DRESS OR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS I DON'T WANT
TO BE REPETITIVE OF WHAT I
MENTIONED FOR.
ABOUT GENERAL THOUGHTS ON OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BUT
EVERYTHING WERE SEEN IN EVERY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBERS
HIGHS PERCENTAGE OF
HOMELESSNESS.
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF CRISIS
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE. THIS IS
A BILL.
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH IS HOUSING THAT IS PAIRED
WHICH SOCIAL SERVICES THAT ARE
TARGETED AND ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN THEIR
HOUSING.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING HAS
BEEN A PROVEN METHOD OF REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AND I WOULD SAY OUR
IT ALSO HAS PROVEN TO BE A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF REDUCING.
ARE THE COSTS WHEN SOMEONE IS
NOT HOUSED YEAH THEY'RE
TYPICALLY INCURRING COSTS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
THE CORRECTION SYSTEM AND
OTHERS.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ORGANIZATIONS
AND DEVELOPERS AROUND STATE THE
BUILDING PERMIT SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. OFTEN TAKES MANY YEARS
BECAUSE OF THE LOCAL APPROVAL
PROCESS
AND THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO STREAMLINE
THE APPROVAL. OF ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS
THAT INCLUDE A MINIMUM
PERCENTAGE OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY EITHER INCLUDE
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
PROJECT THAT IS SUPPORTIVE WORE
A FIFTEEN UNIT MINIMUM.
SERVICES WOULD NEED TO BE
PROVIDED ON SITE.
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WOULD BE
ABLE TO APPLY OBJECTIVE AND
QUANTIFIABLE DESIGN STANDARDS
AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
TREATED LIKE RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING.
INTENT FOR LAWS REALLY TO NOT
CREATE ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING TO TREAT THIS
KIND OF HOUSING LIKE ANY OTHER
RENTAL HOUSING.
THIS BILL WOULD BUILD ON.
THAT PREMISE
AND HOPEFULLY PREVENT
DEVELOPMENTS FROM BEING STALLED
AS RESULT OF LOCAL OPPOSITION.
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE JOINED
BY.
BY MY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COLLEAGUE MISTER DAILY AND I
WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
HIM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
AS THE BILL READS HOMELESSNESS
IN CALIFORNIA HAS REACHED A
CRISIS STAGE.
AND IN MY OPINION SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WHICH THIS BILL
ADDRESSES IS ONE OF THE BETTER
SOLUTIONS TO THE CHALLENGE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY THE DEBATE OVER
HOW AND WHERE TO HOUSE THE
HOMELESS IS NOW BEING MANAGED BY
THE FEDERAL COURTS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
SHELTER BEDS AND ALTERNATIVES.
AND NOT ENOUGH COMMUNITIES.
HAVE STEPPED UP TO ALLOW.
PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
RESEARCHERS AT UC IRVINE IN
ORANGE COUNTY FOUND THAT THE
COST OF SERVICES FOR THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS DECLINED
STEEPLY WHEN THEY ARE PLACED IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
JUST THREE MONTHS AGO A PROJECT
CALLED THE ORCHARD OPENED
IN MY DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
SANTA ANA.
THIS IS THE LARGEST PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT TO
DATE IN THE CITY OF SANTA ANA.
THE DEVELOPER HAS CONVERTED AN
OLD MOTEL INTO A SEVENTY TWO
UNIT COMMUNITY DEDICATED TO
HOUSING CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
THIS PROJECT BRINGS TOGETHER
SEVERAL ENTITIES INCLUDING THE
CITY OF SANTA ANA WHICH IF OF A
PROVIDING RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
AND MERCY HOUSE A NONPROFIT
WHICH IS PROVIDING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR THE NEW RESIDENTS
AND THAT'S THE KEY IT'S FAR MORE
THAN A SHELTER IT'S A. SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
SERVICES ARE FINE TUNED FOR THE
POPULATION TO BE SERVED.
AND THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT A
PROJECT LIKE THAT WILL GET
HOMELESS OFF THE STREETS THERE'S
JUST NO QUESTION.
THAT.
THIS IS PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WILL
HELP PROMOTE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
MORE PROBLEM SOLVING PROJECTS
LIKE THIS ONE. IN AREAS WHERE
CITIES ALREADY PLANNED FOR AND
ALLOW MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE PROJECTS LIKE THIS. MISTER
CHU AN IRA ARE FOCUSED ON.
.
CAN BE.
DEVELOPED IN AREAS WHERE THE.
EXISTING ZONING ALLOWS IT AND
WHAT THE CITY IS SUPPORTIVE FOR
THE CITY OR COUNTY IS
SUPPORTIVE.
SHORTENING THE PLANNING IN
APPROVAL TIMELINE WILL ALSO
REDUCE THE COST OF BUILDING.
WHICH WE HOPE WILL INCENTIVIZE
OTHERS TO CONSTRUCT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN OTHER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE AND I WANNA
THANK MISTER CHIU FOR HIS SO.
VERY VERY FINE WORK ON THIS
SUBJECT.
THIS TIME I LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES I WANT TO THANK
BOTH CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AS WELL AS HOUSING
CALIFORNIA FOR BEER SPONSORS OF
THE BILL. AND TURN IT OVER TO
YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU SAID
WITH OVER FORTY TWO PERCENT OF
THE NATION'S CHRONIC HOMELESS
POPULATION CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED OR HAS A PAST FUNDING.
FOR SOME CRITICAL PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
INCLUDING NO PLACE LIKE HOME
AND HOUSING FOR HEALTHY
CALIORNIA. IN FACT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IS THE ONLY EVIDENCE
BASED INTERVENTION FOR THIS
POPULATION.
AND IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE ONLY
ONE THAT CAN THAT SOLVED LONG
TERM HOMELESSNESS FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF DATA
DEMONSTRATES THAT SUPPORT OF
HOUSING NOT ONLY STABILIZES
PEOPLE IN HOUSING BUT AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED DECREASE ALLOWS
THE TENANTS TO DECREASE THEIR.
HEALTH CARE CHILD WELFARE.
AND CORRECTIONS COSTS.
IT ALSO HAS THE BENEFIT OF
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR THE
TENANTS.
DATA ALSO SHOW THAT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IMPROVES PROPERTY VALUES
AND DECREASES BLIGHT AND THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH IT'S BELT.
YES SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO BUILD IT REQUIRES
AN AVERAGE OF THIRTEEN SOURCES
OF FUNDING FOR THE CAPITAL
OPERATING AND SERVICES COSTS.
TO BE COMPETITIVE FOR THIS
FUNDING SUPPORT OF HOUSING MUST
BE GREENER. IT MUST BE MORE
SECURE.
IT MUST OFFER MORE INTENSIVE
SERVICES AND IT MUST SERVE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
THEN.
THAN MARKET RATE HOUSING.
DESPITE GOING THROUGH ALL OF
THESE HURDLES TO GET SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROJECTS FUNDED.
DEVELOPERS HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
BUILDING SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
BECAUSE OF CITING.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF AN MD ISM.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WOULD
ALLOW SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROVIDERS.
TO RECIEVE BY RIGHT APPROVAL
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECTS
AS LEARNED LIST LONG A CERTAIN
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS ARE MET.
IT ENSURES DEVELOPMENTS MAY BE
BUILT MORE QUICKLY MEETING A
GOAL EXPRESSED BY MULTIPLE
LEGISLATORS TO GET OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS HOUSE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WELL WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT.
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE WILL
ALLOW MANY OF THESE PROJECTS TO
MOVE FORWARD. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY TWO WOULD FURTHER EXPEDITE
THE REVIEW PROCESS.
IT WOULD ALSO PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITIES EXCLUDED
FROM S. B. THIRTY FIVE.
AND THEY WILL APPLY TO FARM MORE
PROJECTS THAN HER FAR MORE SITES
THAN S. B. THIRTY FIVE WELL.
AND ADDRESSING ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS TO CREATING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING CITING.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TO TAKES A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND WE
REALLY WANT TO THINK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAIRMAN THE CO AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL AND.
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TYRONE BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
I'M I WOULD CONCUR WITH.
MUCH OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL.
THE ONE THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT.
IN THE IN TAKING A HOUSING
CRISIS SERIOUSLY LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFIED THAT
NAME BE ISM IS PLAYING. A LARGE
ROLE IN THE CREATION OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE'VE SEEN
THE LEGISLATURE.
PUSH FOR PROPOSALS SEEKING TO
ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM AND APPLY
STREAMLINING.
OFTEN TO MARKET RATE HOUSING.
AND SO THE VALUE OF THIS BILL
IS THAT IT REALLY PUSHES.
THAT. PROPOSAL AND THAT
STRATEGY TO SOME THE MOST
DIFFICULT HOUSING TO CITE AND
COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH THAT I'M WERE VERY.
PLEASE STAND UP THINK FOR THE
AUTHOR AUTHORS HAVE BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AND.
ARE.
HONOR TO SPONSOR IN SPORTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
A PUBLIC COMMENT OR ASK FOR
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AN ORGANIZATION ON
THE RECORD.
BRIAN AUGUST ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
I KNOW LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL YET BUT
WE RECOGNIZE THE DIRE NEED TO
GET MORE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING UNITS BUILT AND THAT'S
WHY WE REQUESTED. A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FROM THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET SURPLUS TO FRONT LOAD THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM AND
GET THAT PROGRAM STARTED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. SO I THINK
IN RELATION TO THAT I THINK WERE
ALSO WILLING TO HAVE THE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO ON THE LAND YOU
SIDE TO FACILITATE THE FASTER
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE UNITS. AND
WE WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE CONSULTANT AND TO
CONTINUE TO REFINE SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES. BUT I THINK THE BIG
REMAINING THINGS FOR US ARE
GONNA BE CLARIFYING THE INTENT
WITH REGARD TO THE ZONING
STANDARDS THAT WOULD APPLY TO
THESE PROJECTS. I'M DISCUSSING
WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO BE ANY
SORT OF FILTER ABOUT THE SITES
WHERE WOULD APPLY. AND THEN
MAKING SURE SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL THINGS SUCH AS THE
TIME LIMITS AND THE PARKING
STANDARDS MAKE SENSE FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT CONTEXTS WHERE THEY
CAN APPLY BUT. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION AND HOPE TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE WE CAN SUPPORT THE
BILL.
YOU SIR. ODDS THAT'S WHAT THOUGH
THOSE ARE THE SUPPORTERS WHO IS
A SPEAKERS OPPOSITION THIS
MORNING.
CNN WILL RETURN UP HERE TO THE
DYESS AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITMENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS DR WHAT.
WELL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR BOTH OF YOU APPRECIATE
THIS.
I THINK YOU'VE HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD EARLIER MISTER CHIU
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND HOUSING
AND HOW THAT IMPACTS HEALTHCARE
WE ALL THAT WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL
FROM OUR HEARINGS RECENTLY THAT.
WE AND IN THE UNITED STATES
ONLY SPEND ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR FOR EVERY
DOLLAR WE SPEND ON HEALTHCARE
FOR FOR HOW FOR SOCIAL SERVICES.
WHERE IS OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE MUCH BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES
A SPEND TWICE THAT WERE ACTUALLY
FOUR TIMES AT ALMOST TWO DOLLARS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND ON
HEALTHCARE SO? SO THE MORE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES MORE HOUSING
WE HAVE I THINK CAN REALLY HELP.
THE POPULATION THAT NEEDS IT
THE MOST AND ALSO HAVE A
POSITIVE PACKED OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
BUT TREASURE FROM HANS
QUESTIONS.
YES I DO IDEA AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE.
ASSEMBLY CHOOSE HAVE FOR THE
ADDRESS OF THIS OMINOUS. MISSY
ISSUE.
I WONDER WHAT THE.
ONCE THE WATER LE.
YEAH TAKE MY A.
SUCH GESTION TO AMANDA IN.
.
TO SAVE DATA.
TO ALLOW.
ALL THE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
NOT JUST A.
OUR OF WHAT MORE FOR HOMELESS.
NO PEOPLE BECAUSE SESSION ON.
YEAH THIS IS SO PROBABLY
INTENDED TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING TIME WISE AND ALSO
AGREED TO STOP COST OF THE
BUILDING.
AND THE GOVERNMENT. APPROVAL
PROCESS SO IT'S OUT FOR IT TAKES
JUST A LITTLE TOO LONG AND
COSTLY AND THAT THAT DRIVES UP
BUT THE HOUSING COSTA.
SO ARE NOT YOU WORKING PEOPLE I
THINK ARE I'M WAR INTERESTED AND
PREVENTING.
TO BEGIN WITH THE HOMELESSNESS.
DE AND ALL IT IT PASS HOLDER
RANGE UP WHAT TOPICS WE CAN TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW.
IT ARE DEVELOPING IN A
BUSINESSES AND UP IN A JOB SET
TO BEGIN WITH THE. END OF IT.
NO. NO WAIT WE CAN CALL BACK OF
WHERE THE. PROBLEM BEGINS SEPT
ARTE. HOUSING COSTS A HIGH
HOUSING COSTS THAT IS SO.
ON ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ARE TYPICALLY TALK ABOUT.
BUT THE RATHER THAN.
HELPING.
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR HOMELESS
PEOPLE. WHAT ABOUT THE?
ALLOWING ALL ALL THE.
.
DEVELOPERS SO. A TO BENEFIT US
SO THAT THE WORKING FAMILY THE.
MEET PRICE TO.
A MARKET PRICED.
HOME CELL WOULD BENEFIT THE SAME
WAY BYPASSING THE SIKH Y. WERE
REQUIREMENTS AND THE LOCAL
ZONING BECAUSE IT THIS IS
BASICALLY WE TRY TO BYPASS
THOUGH SO.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO THAT.
SO I THINK THAT YOU AND I BOTH
SHARE AND I THINK ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE SURE
THE GOAL OF WANTING TO.
MOVED FOR HOUSING CREATION MORE
QUICKLY LAST YEAR YOU MAY
REMEMBER WE HAD A VERY ROBUST
DEBATE ON WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED THIS VERY SPECIFIC
IDEA. OF HOW WE STREAMLINED.
HOUSING CREATION AT ALL LEVELS
OF THE HOUSING MARKET A SB
THIRTY FIVE WAS HOTLY DEBATED
AND I CAME THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE AND PARTS OF S. B.
THIRTY FIVE WHICH STREAMLINED.
MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT.
AND DEVELOPMENT AT ALL LEVELS
OF AFFORDABILITY I HAD A BILL I
THINK YOU SUPPORTED IT AB
SEVENTY THREE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH INCENTIVES
FOR THE STREAMLINING OF PROJECTS
AGAIN AT ALL LEVELS. OF
AFFORDABILITY SO WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THIS PARTICULAR
BILL THOUGH HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
PERMITS PORT OF HOUSING BECAUSE
THERE HAD BEEN. MIGHT MANY MORE
PARTICULAR REASONS WHY THESE
SORTS PROJECTS ARE ARE BEING
BLOCKED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THEY'RE TREATED
LIKE OTHERS AND.
THINK THE LAST THING I WILL SAY
IS.
A YOU'D REFERENCE EARLIER THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE DOLLARS THAT
WE SPENT BEING SPENT.
WELL AND WISELY AND WE'VE MADE
A LOT OF INVESTMENTS AND HAS A
STATE TO PROVIDE THEM TO
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER.
PERMANENT SOURCE.
DEVELOPERS AND YET THEY HAVE TO
SPEND YEARS DEALING WITH THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS IN THE
APPROVAL PROCESS. AND THE POINT
OF THIS BILL IS TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESS FOR FOR FOR THE SUPPORT
OF HOUSING.
DEVELOPERS SO THAT RATHER THAN
THE MONEY GOING INTO THE PROCESS
THAT ACTUALLY GOES INTO.
TO TO PUTTING A ROOF OVER
SOMEONE'S HEAD SO.
THE DISCUSSION THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED I THINK HOUSE WE WE'VE
HAD IN THIS COMMITTEE THIS PAST
YEAR I THINK IT'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION I'M HAPPYTO.
ENGAGE IT.
OUT WITH OTHER BILLS BUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE THAT THE PLIGHT IT
THAT IS FACING THOSE THAT ARE
TRYING TO BUILD MORE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
YEAH I KNOW YOU ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS OUT THERE RIGHT NOW WILL
NOT SHOW UP PEOPLE AND TIMES
MAKE THE HOMES UP TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR THEM BUT
I'M TRYING TO.
IN A SOFT THE BASIC PROBLEM HERE
TO BEGIN WITH THE WE CAN ROLL
WITH THE HOUSING COSTS HOW MUCH
IT IMPACT. BUT THEY SHOULD HELP
US HOA RATHER THAN IN A YOU KNOW
PROVIDING.
WE HAVE NOT A SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM SET TO BEGIN WITH YOU
CAN PREVENT UP A KNOWING. NOW
CAN WE HOPE OR THAT THE
GOVERNMENT THE REGULATIONS THAT.
BEGIN WITH AN APPROVAL PROCESS
THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M INTERESTED.
UNDERSTOOD.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA.
BUT MET AGAIN AT IT LAST YEAR WE
SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME ON
THAT VERY QUESTION AND I THINK
WE WERE ABLE TO GET.
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT BILLS
THROUGH THAT ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED AS WE SPEAK THAT TO
YOUR POINT WOULD STREAMLINE.
THE CREATION OF HOUSING AT ALL
LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY
INCLUDING HERE POINT MARKET RATE
DEVELOPMENT SO I I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A WORTHY CONVERSATION.
THAT WE HAVE HAD AND WILL SEE
THE IMPACT OF THOSE BILLS THIS
BILL THOUGH WAS ONE THAT WE
DIDN'T DO LAST YEAR TO REALLY
DRESS IN THE SITUATIONS THAT
FACE.
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THAT NEED
PERMITS APARTMENT MAYBE YOU CAN
CLARIFY ONE QUESTION I HAVE HERE
IS SAYS SO REQUIRES A CITIES
AND.
COUNTIES.
TO APPROVE.
IT IN THE BEGINNING A CO OR THE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR RULER SORT
THE.
BY PASSED
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A CITIES.
COUNTY SO TO APPROVE.
NOTE THE STATUS DE LA ALLOW.
IN A CITIES AND.
TONY SO LOCAL ZONING
REQUIREMENTS. HOPE WHICH ONE
WOULD PROCEED NO MISTER CHU AND
I ARE BOTH THE.
FORMER LOCAL OFFICIALS HE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
ME IN ANAHEIM.
AND.
YOU KNOW THERE'S GENERAL PLANS
THAT CITIES MUST.
ABIDE BY THEIR LOCAL ZONING.
REQUIREMENTS AND.
.
THIS BILL SIMPLY.
GIVES THE CITY ADDITIONAL TOOLS
TO PROCESS PROJECTS WHICH COMPLY
WITH LOCAL ZONING SO THAT'S VERY
KEY.
THERE'S NO STATE. OVERRIDE HERE.
.
IN TERMS OF ZONING.
SO IF THE ZONING FITS
THEN THE PROJECT.
IS CONSIDERED WORTHY.
SO I'LL HOW. HOW WERE YOU THAT
IN EVERY CITIES DIFFERENT ARENA
CITY OF A CITY LIKE?
Y. DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE YEAH
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE A FRANKLY
APPROACH OF THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS PROBABLY. A WOULD BE
UNLIKELY IN THE CITY LIKE IRVINE
WHERE EVERY SQUARE INCH HAS BEEN
MASTER PLANNED AND ZONED.
AND.
AND THEIR.
IS BASICALLY.
NO. ONE MAJOR A DEVELOPER IN
TOWN.
WELL I THINK THIS BILL FITS
OLDER COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE
ARE OLD SAY ROADSIDE MOTELS.
FIFTY SIXTY SEVENTY YEARS OLD
AND.
AND THE IN SOME CASES THOSE ARE.
ARE NOW A HOUSING FOR
TRANSIENTS
OR OR.
MAYBE A PROBLEMATIC PROJECTS IN
THE CITY WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
SOMETHING TOM.
THAT FITS AT TIMES A LITTLE BIT
BETTER.
AND SO IF IT'S ZONED FOR
RESIDENTIAL.
THEN A PROJECT LIKE THIS.
.
WELL QUALIFIED.
BUT THE CITY STILL HAS TO BE
SUPPORTIVE I THINK THAT.
THE MAIN.
ANSWER HERE SIR IS THAT.
.
I'M A CITY HAS TO BE COMFORTABLE
WITH PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
I I HOPE SO BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
IN MY DISTRICT BUT THEY CLEARLY
IN THE CITY OF. IRVINE SO
CONTROVERSY AS A GOING ON.
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED ACRE SAVA TONY
LAND.
WHETHER THAT'S A SEPTIC TO US
CITIES.
ZONING REGULATIONS. AND THE
KALLONI ACTS ARE LIKE A IS NOT
SO.
BEFORE.
THE SUPERVISORS US SUGGESTION
TO PETER DOT POWER SEEING FOR
HOMELESS PEOPLE. A COUPLE DAYS
AGO UP PRIOR TO THAT THE EVEN A
VERY HIGH DENSITY OF COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE COUNTY WANTED TO. COME
UP GOAL WITH THAT THE HOWEVER
NASSAU FASTEST CITY.
REQUIRED. THAT RIFLE THROUGH
ZONING PROCESS AND UP PROCESS
AND THE NORTH THAT'S NOT THE
CASE AND WHAT THE CITY WILL HAVE
PLENTY OF CONTROL A WITH ITS.
ZONING POWERS.
I'M A LITTLE WHEN SHE IS PASS IS
TAUGHT THIS WHERE AGAIN. ARE AT
THAT ADDITIONAL IN NOT MUCH.
WELL WHAT WHAT W. WE HAVE A
WHOLE KIND OF WHAT LOCAL
AUTHORITIES OR HALF OF THE OPEN
CHORE ON THEIR OWN FATE DEL ON
THE US TUNING REGULATIONS OF
PASSED MY WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT.
YEAH I IN MY OPINION THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT PROTECTIONS FOR
CITIES IN THIS BILL.
IF I COULD JUST AS PART OF A
CONVERSATION JUST POINT OUT YOU
U. S. SORT OF TWO THINGS ON THE
ONE HAND YOU WANT STREAMLINED
HOUSING AND ON THE OTHER HAND
YOU'RE SAYING LOCAL. GOVERNMENTS
OUGHT TO HAVE CONTROL OVER WHAT
THAT HOUSING HAS I WOULD SUBMIT
I THINK WE WOULD PROBABLY AGREE.
THAT OFTENTIMES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ADDING ALL
SORTS OF OWNERS CONDITIONS ONTO
THESE PROJECTS OF THAT THEY
DON'T GET BILLED SO. I THINK THE
GOAL IS TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
ARE WHAT WE'RE SAYING HERE IS
THAT THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT IF
THEY MEET THE ZONING ARE IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS THEY SHOULD BE
ENCUMBERED WITH ADDITIONAL
CONDITIONS THAT WOULD SLOW IT
DOWN. OR OTHERWISE ADD YEARS FOR
THESE PROJECTS TO GET BUILT SO
UP SO TO.
MY COLLEAGUE.
MIGHT MY JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS.
THE IDEA IS.
LOCALS WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
DICTATE WHAT THEIR ZONING RULES
ARE.
BUT WE'RE ALSO SAYING TO A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPER IS IF YOU MEET THOSE
CONDITIONS YOU SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO TOUCH YOUR PROJECT MOVE FOR
WITHOUT BEING AND.
ENCUMBER FOR MANY YEARS.
YOU SEE THAT BOUNCE.
SO.
MISTER CHAIR YES.
BUT CHOI THANK YOU.
I WILL MAKE A MOTION TO ADVANCE
A.
THIS
IT'S LEGISLATION I'M I'M I JUST
QUICK QUESTIONS FOR OF FOR THE
AUTHOR.
IN THE STATE IS WHAT.
.
I'M OFF FOR THIS IN I THINK THAT
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING TO IS THE
IDEA THAT CONCEPTUALLY AND I
ALSO SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IT'S ONE THING TO PASS A GENERAL
PLANS WHEN THEY TO PASS A
COMMUNITY PLAN IT'S ON A VERY
HIGH LEVEL BE SINGS A FINE WHEN
SOMEONE SHOWS UP WITH THAT
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT AND SAYS THAT
APARTMENT MULTI FAMILY. COMPLEX
YOU WERE THINKING ABOUT IS GONNA
BE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS WE HAVE
SEEN IN MANY CASES THE PROJECTS
TO SLOW DOWN.
AND THERE'S A MILLION ONE
REASONS TO SLOW WALK OR TO TRY
AND A A NOT ADVANCE THESE
PROJECTS THAT AS YOU KNOW IS
HAPPY IN A CONTEXT OF EXTREME.
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT SO THE INTENT OF
THE BILL IS I THINK ON A
SALEABLE. THE ONE THING I WILL
SAY IS I'M ALWAYS CONSERVATIVE
AS WE TRY PUSHY NBA AGENDA
APPEAL TO THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE ADDRESS.
HOUSING CRISIS
IS THAT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
UNDERMINES THE PUBLIC'S BELIEF
IN WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. AND
SO IN THIS REGARD I HAVE
PERSONALLY SEEN THAT CONDITIONAL
USE PERMITS CAN BE HELPFUL IN IN
CAPTURING SCOTT PUBLIC SUPPORT.
FOR PROJECTS THAT HAVE ONSITE
SERVICES.
MY READING OF THE OF THE.
DOCUMENTS PROVIDED FOR THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IS THAT THIS
IS FOR A PURPOSE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WITH THE SERVICES ARE
LIMITED TO THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THE COMPLEX.
IS THAT CORRECT MISTER CHAIR.
THAT IS.
THAT IS MY IN TENSE NAM IS
THERE.
GIVE ANYTHING LIKE TO ELABORATE
ON THAT IT ACTUALLY DOES IT.
SERVICES HAVE TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE TENANTS IN THE PROJECT IT
DOES NOT LIMIT THE SERVICES TO.
PEOPLE LIVING THERE SO FOR
EXAMPLE SOME SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS BUILD OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS ON THE FIRST
FLOOR. THOSE WOULD NOT BE
LIMITED TO JUST THE RESIDENTS
UNDER THIS BILL I THINK MOST OF
THE TIME SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
JUST PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
RESIDENTS.
BUT THERE ARE SOME OCCASIONS
WERE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
PROVIDING
AS I MENTIONED CLINICAL CARE TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL.
AND SO THAT'S THE RIGHT NOW IN
GUY LIKE ME AND YOUNG OR MY PETS
BUT IT ON THE STAFF.
I'M ALL IN FAVOR RIGHT BUT I DO
KNOW THAT WHEN YOU START
INVITING FOLKS MY OUTSIDE OF THE
COMPLEX THE RESIDENTS OF THAT
COMMUNITY THE NEIGHBORS.
THEN THINGS GET A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT RIGHT IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ANY SORT OF ONSITE
FEEDING PROGRAMS
BUT I AM NOT HEALTH CLINIC RIGHT
IT'S WHEN THEY DIVIDE SERVICES
FOR THE FOLKS ARE THERE. IN USE
NOTHING MISTER DALY MISTER
CHOOSE POINT IF YOU'RE TELLING
AS A MARKET RATE FOR THE HOUSE
OF MARKET RATE HOUSING PROJECT
THE ONSITE SERVICES ARE THE GEM
OF FOR THE RESIDENTS OR THE FIRE
PIT FOR THE RESIDENTS OR
WHATEVER. NO CONDITIONAL USE
PERMITS OR.
RIGHT BUT WHEN YOU START PROVIDE
SERVICES WHICH IS THE SAME THING
I HAVE TO BE DONE POPULATIONS OF
THE SERVICE IS DIFFERENT BUT
ALSO WE START BUTTON. RULES IN
AGAINST SLOWING DOWN THE PROCESS
THE PROJECT BECOMES AN UNTENABLE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO TO
SOLVE. I THINK WHAT HAPPENS AND
WHERE WE START TO LOSE PUBLIC
SUPPORT IS IF THESE PROJECTS ARE
BUILT IN THERE'S QUEUING OUTSIDE
OF THE BUILDING RIGHT FOLKS
LINED UP FOR LUNCH OR FOR
DINNER.
IF YOU SEEN YOU KNOW.
AFFAIR NOT HEAVY TRAFFIC THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
TEND TO I THINK ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SUPPORT AND TRUST THE I GET A
SENSE OF PEOPLE MORE OPEN TO
THIS COULD SEE HOW BAD THE
CONDITIONS ARE. AND SOMEONE
UNDERMINE THAT AND I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO USE THAT WHEN I WAS A C.
COUNCIL MEMBER TO GET I THINK
WERE THE CONDITIONAL USE PERMITS
THAT REALLY LIMIT THAT AND
PROVIDES A LEVEL OF CERTAINTY. I
THINK THE THREE EXAMPLES IN MY
TIME IN THE CITY COUNCIL AYE WE
STAB US AS A PART OF MITCHELL
USE PERMIT PROCESS AYE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
OUT COMMITTEE I DID THAT MONTH
OF MONTHLY TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROJECT RIGHT. IN EACH OF THOSE
INSTANCES THOSE COMMITTEES
DISBANDED AFTER A SHORT AMOUNT
TIME BECAUSE THE CONCERNS OF
THEY HAD IN DEMAND IN THE CP. I
WERE NOT THOSE THOSE CONCERNS
NEVER CAME TO FRUITION. POINT IS
THEY GOT I GOT TO THE POINT FOR
THE APPROVAL NOW THE BILL IS
KIND OF INTO THE DISTORTION GO
AROUND THAT AND NOT HAVE THAT
BUT. I QUESTION WHETHER NOT THE
WISDOM THERE'S WISDOM BEHIND
DOING THAT AND IN AND TAKING
AWAY.
SOME OF THE SAFETIES.
MECHANISMS THAT ARE THERE. FOR
OFF SITE SERVICES AGAIN I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY IS LIKE FOR
LIKE MULTI FAMILY MULTI FAMILY
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BEING OF
ECONOMIC WRONG OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SERVING THEIR.
THEN THAT'S PROBABLY FIND WHAT
HELP PLAN THE PROJECTS.
AND PERHAPS LIMIT SOME FEATURES
IF IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE OF THE
CITY'S FINANCIAL INVOLVEMENT
THERE MAY BE OTHER PROJECTS.
IN OTHER PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE THERE WON'T WHERE THE CITY
WON'T BE A FINANCIAL PARTNER.
BUT THE PROJECTS I'M FAMILIAR
WITH.
THERE IS THAT LEVEL OF CITY
INVOLVEMENT.
AND SO.
I THINK THERE'S APPROPRIATE.
MY VIEW THEIR APPROPRIATE
CONTROLS YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN.
BUT I THINK IT'S A PROJECT BY
PROJECT.
THE DECISION.
THERE WILL BE SMALLER PROJECTS
THERE WILL BE LARGER PROJECTS IT
DEPENDS ON THE ACREAGE.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW OLDER
COMMUNITIES HAVE DIFFERENT LAND
USE HISTORIES.
.
AND.
AND SO IT'S WITH THIS REALLY
NOT A COOKIE CUTTER OF.
.
SITUATION.
SO WERE I THINK
ALSO I THINK BECAUSE THE CRISIS
WERE IN WE HAVE TO TRY. VARIOUS
TOOLS.
AND MECHANISMS AND WE CAN ALWAYS
REVISIT THOSE.
I'VE HAD SOME PUSH BACK IN MY
DISTRICT OVER THE CONCEPT OF
GRANNY UNITS.
BECAUSE THERE WERE SO MANY.
ON PERMITTED GRAINY UNITS GOING
BACK SEVENTY FIVE YEARS.
WELL THE REALITY IS THERE ARE
HAVEN'T BEEN VERY MANY
APPLICATIONS TO BUILD THOSE NEW
PERMITS.
AND THE CITIES DO HAVE THE EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE.
ENABLED IN CONCEPT MORE BRANDY
UNITS A CITY STILL HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF OF CONTROL.
.
AND SO THE REALITIES SOMETIMES
THE FEARS DON'T MATCH THE
REALITY SO AND THOSE SO THAT'S
MY HOPE WITH THIS BILL.
AND THAT WHILE YOU WERE ASKING
THE QUESTION I JUST SKIMMED THE
THE LEGISLATION TO TO LOOK AT
THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICE
PROVISIONS AND. I ALWAYS SAY IN
THIS BILL IS THAT THERE SHALL BE
A MINIMUM.
EITHER NUMBER SQUARE FEET OF
NINETY SQUARE FEET FOR A
DEVELOPMENTS OF TWENTY OR FEWER
UNITS FOR ON SITE SUPPORTIVE OR
FOR DEVELOPMENTS WITH MORE THAN
TWENTY UNITS AT LEAST THREE
PERCENT OF THE. A NON RESIDENT
FLOOR AREA TO BE PRESENTED TO
THAT ARE SO THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST CONVERSATION HAVING WITH A
COLLEAGUE ABOUT THIS TOPIC I'M
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON
THIS.
AND.
AND HAPPY TO ALSO GET SPONSORS
AS WE DO WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU'VE JUST RAISED YEAH WELL AND
I APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN AGAIN
I'M ON BILL I MAKE THE MOTION
I'M
I THINK IT DOES SOLVE A A REAL
PROBLEM THAT WE SEE. ACROSS
STATE.
BUT IN THAT THROUGH IN THE
PASSAGE I THINK YOUR FRIEND TO
ON PAGE TWO OF THE STAFF REPORT.
AYE THE MENTION OF COMMUNITY
KITCHENS I MEAN E. ESTABLISHING
A SUPPORT HOUSING COMPLEX DEEP
IN A RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY WITH
A COMMUNITY KITCHEN THAT
CONSERVE THE RESIDENTS I GOT IT.
SERVING A BROADER SET OF A
COMMUNITY THAT BECOMES A
DIFFERENT THING AND I'M THAT'S
TYPICALLY WHEN A CONDITIONAL USE
PERMIT IS APPROPRIATE I'M AYE
BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATION STRIPS
THAT OUT. AND WE SHOULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT AGAIN
AYE AYE TILT MORE TOWARDS MORE
HOUSING WHAT'S PERMISSIBLE OF
HOUSING GET MORE PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS ASAP.
BUT THERE'S PROBABLY.
SOME SOME THOUGHT THAT WE
SHOULD GIVE TO HOW WE DO THIS TO
MAKE SURE I'M THAT WERE NOT.
THEY WERE DANCING THE PRODUCTION
AND NOT THE OPPOSITION FROM THE.
CEMEX.
.
I SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTION
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SPEAK ON THIS MATTER.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MYSELF IT
WAS SECONDED BY DOCTOR WOULD.
MISTER CHIU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AYE I JUST APPRECIATE THE
THE COMMITTEES CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF US ALSO WANT TO
THANK ALL OF MY JOINTS AUTHOR ON
THIS.
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
GOAL OF OF TRYING TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS A
CALIFORNIANS AND I THINK THIS IS
A PART PART OF THAT SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
YES.
AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF MY
COLLEAGUE.
MISTER CHU AND YOUR POINT IS
VERY WELL TAKEN MISTER GLORIA
AND I THINK WE'LL.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS A.
THE TO ASSURE OF THE CITY'S
THAT THEY'LL HAVE SUFFICIENT.
NO POWERS.
TO
IT'S JIM IS VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH QUICKLY KALRA.
MOTION TO PASSING REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
STEINORTH.
SHOWING NO SHOWING NO GLORIA
I'VE GLORIA AYE LAMONT.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
DALY AYE DALY AYE.
CHIU AYE CHOO AYE.
THAT PASSES FOR ONE. THANK YOU.
WE DON'T THINK YOU.
SURE WE I KEEP SEVERAL OPEN
OTHER SOME NUMBERS THAT WERE
STILL EXPECTING COME DOWN A
VOTE.
OKAY ONE WE JUST WAIT ONE MOMENT
BUT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FORA.
FOR UP RUNNING THIS MEETING
THANK YOU SHARE I WILL PROBLY
WONT WAIT ONE MORE MINUTE FOR
ADD ONS IN CASE THERE ARE ANY.
I HAD
CLOSE THE MEETING OF TODAY WE
ARE TURNED